I told you about this story last month
Texas mom who mysteriously disappeared
before hurricane Harvey made landfall
crystal McDowell was reported missing
after she failed to pick up her two
children from her ex-husband police
officers while battling the hurricane
narrowed down their search to three
persons of interest 48 hours
correspondent maureen maher got
exclusive access to this investigation
that finally led to an arrest what are
you doing today Christa McDowell and her
husband Steve were flying high she was a
successful realtor and mother of two
crystal always had a great spirit about
her crystal could take care of herself
when her 10-year marriage fell apart she
did not after divorce there was a new
man in her life
a jeweler Paul Hargrave you know when
you first meet somebody and you're kind
of cloud 9
Friday morning August 25th is when she
left the house she stated that she had
to pick up her kids before her ex went
to work but she never showed up with
flood waters rising her worried uncle
Jeff Walters called 9-1-1 Chambers
County Sheriff's Office our main
objective is just to get crystals back
oh we're just gonna get this thing
started young Chambers County Sheriff
Bryan Hawthorne and District Attorney
Cheryl Leake granted 48 hours
unprecedented access into their war room
in interviewing Stephen is denying
knowing Paul existed until two days ago
as they tried to unravel the mystery of
where was crystal this is a case about
lots of Secrets double lives on many
people's parts I've never seen anything
like this before
investigators searched for clues by
looking at those closest to crystal some
of the investigators that were involved
in this would say you know I I think
it's Steve and some would say I still
can't get over Jeff and I'm still
looking at Paul everyone came in to the
Sheriff's Department and was questioned
finally deputies got their first lead
when Crystal's black Mercedes
was found in a flooded motel 6 parking
lot weather and time deteriorate
evidence physical evidence soon one
suspect would emerge deputies discovered
video surveillance tape they say shows
someone who looked just like Crystal's
ex-husband Steve McDowell dumping her
car we didn't have enough to arrest him
investigators were closed turning up the
heat on Steve McDowell when they took
his children away he began to brake
promising to come into the Sheriff's
Department after he talked to his older
daughter he told her Texas Rangers were
coming for him and I asked him do you
know where the body is and he just like
looked away from me and just bawled his
eyes out what did you think at that
point I literally dropped my knees and
just cried Mauri Mauri you had amazing
access on this story we really did we
were there right from the very beginning
and they let us follow them pretty much
everywhere they went doo doo officials
believe that the storm provided a moment
of opportunity for him that this was
planned out at the time there was a lot
of speculation right so investigators
don't think it was planned to coincide
as a means to cover up the murder but I
do think that it certainly helped for a
couple of weeks but eventually he is
arrested he's charged with first-degree
murder the problem may be for the
prosecution is that in Texas you can
claim sudden passion so even the first
degree can carry up to 99 years he could
get as little as two years so what they
were totally divorced right yes they had
been divorced it was official in June
and what was the motive
he was jealous jealousy and also she was
his meal ticket in a lotta way she was
the breadwinner she was the one who
brought the money home he had a lot of
expensive toys and now not only did she
have a new boyfriend but she had
recently according to one family member
said that's it the toys are done I've
given you the house you have you're
taken care of and I'm really trying to
move on with my life
yeah such a sense of loss you look at
those two beautiful children into the
picture stunning it makes no sense thank
you very much your brain you can see
Maureen's full report on 48 hours it's
called storm of suspicion that's
tomorrow night at 10:00 9:00 central
right here on CBS